hey leute und willkommen zu diesem
snapshot preview von der leihkräfte 12 w
21 asus mittlerweile glaube ich ich habe
das ja schon lange nicht mehr gemacht
einfach weil ich bei den letzten updates
nie so große änderungen gefunden habe
aber dieses update ist ja mal echt
wirklich ziemlich geil und sogar ich als
eigentlich update verabscheue sind das
relativ egal was man jetzt hier
mittlerweile mitmachen kann und zwar
fange ich mal direkt für mit diesen
denner desert dellert damit diesen
evergreen the sun also aus deutsche
übersetzt wüsten dörfer das sind einfach
solche dörfer die sonst irgendwo
aufgetreten sind in einer ganz normalen
landschaft gibt es jetzt auch in der
wüste mit solchen steinen ich hab das
jemals gebaut weil ich keins gefunden
habe ich habe das auf bildern in
minecraft forum gesehen dass die
ungefähr so aussehen davon gibt es dann
halt so fünf sechs häuser in einem ja in
einem dorf sag ich mal da hinten
übrigens schöne landschaften bei diesem
sieht
und die treten jetzt hat mittlerweile
auch so algorithmus generiert auf und da
sportler inhalte auch dorfbewohner hier
war vorhin noch einmal drin also ich hab
hier welche reinen teleportiert weil
hier hin habe ich dann das bauen lassen
und da komme ich einfach gleich noch mal
hin und zwar könnt ihr nun mit diesen
dorfbewohnern endlich handeln und dafür
einfach rechtsklick auf diesen typen
dann drauf machen und der sagt euch zum
beispiel ja ich hätte gerne acht
goldbarren und dafür gebe ich euch ein
emerald diamanten also sondern grün die
haben das ist eine währung hat in der
wir neun goldbarren dafür gibt dazu ein
das hier ist einer der will 16 rutschen
dafür gibt uns einen diamanten und du
willst 16 papier dafür kriegsbilder den
diamanten und ich muss dem dann jetzt
zum beispiel diese 26 papiere geben ich
hole mir dann mal eben diese werte wo
haben wir in ihr papier damals papier so
nicht tun jetzt hier zum beispiel
da 26 okay gut jetzt hat er hier 26
papier und dafür kriege ich einen
diamanten das heißt wir haben es quasi
gehandelt so es gibt natürlich auch
leute die dann irgendwie einen diamanten
haben wollen guckt die hier ja zum der
hier zum beispiel der wir jetzt hier
drei diamanten haben das backteam noch
ein bisschen und dann gibt es ein
bücherregal also dass es ganz cool dass
wir uns einfach sachen er tauschen kann
also wenn ihr zum beispiel nur na gut
wenn ihr zb bei dem tipp da hinten nur
rotes fähnchen mit ab dabei wollten
diamanten dann tauschte das zum beispiel
gegen alters der doof da tauscht das zum
beispiel gegnern diamanten dann könnt
ihr euch von dem diamanten wieder zum
beispiel bei diesem typen dann hier ein
apfel von kaufen oder sich metzel oder
habt ihr was zu essen und so dann habt
ihr quasi nach auf 16 hähnchen 7 äpfel
dann macht was ein blöder tausch ist
aber egal ihr habt halt gehandelt
und jetzt fragt ihr euch bestimmt hey
was sind das für komische diamanten das
sind neue währungsraums habe ich immer
persönlich getauft und zwar kommen die
aus solchen ärzten raus ihr einfach so
in den verschiedensten höhlen findet
glaube ich dass man die in den höhlen
findet ich bin mir da nicht so sicher
ich glaube es waren höhlen jedenfalls
denke ich mal dass man die innen in
welchen hören bekommt dann hat man halt
diese thema tauschen kann aber ich denke
dass sie ziemlich selten sein werden na
ja und was ich auch ziemlich geil finde
ihr könnt jetzt einfach so hier obsidian
hin packen und in die mitte ein ende
auge wartet man dass ich packe ich eben
zur seite das hatte ich mir nur unnötig
er tauscht
das nicht mal dahin so alles gut dann
kriegt er eine ändert also rings von
obsidian mittendrin ein ende auge und
dieses könnte jetzt einfach irgendwo
hinstellen und dann kann ich ja zum
beispiel dieser test hier 38 davon und
davon vier äpfel reicht und wenn ihr
jetzt wo ich noch geändert testmarkt zum
beispiel irgendwo dahinten in der höhle
wo er dann eben wie diamant sachen drin
packt conti reingucken habe meine sachen
und dann kann ich zum beispiel hier
jetzt noch mal äpfel reinlegen und hier
alle meine sachen zum beispiel in der
höhe und lage alle meine sachen sterne
der zurück zu meinem platz hier redet
anlage spot wird mir hinterlassen dann
kann ich die ganzen sachen die wir
rausholen das ist quasi einfach so
internet icloud sowie apple das jetzt
entwickelt dass man das alles einfach so
teilen kann sag ich mal so nächste
änderungen sind es enstone stars die ihr
euch so ganz einfach machen können
warum die das jetzt gerade nicht
was habe ich falsch gemacht oder
oder ging das ausland ich bin mir nicht
sicher voraus ging das ja ich hab's doch
vorher noch hingekriegt worauf ich das
denn ich habe keine ahnung worauf sich
das gemacht habe jedenfalls
haben wir die dann hier wir haben das
fenster und slams und die können wir
dann auch ganz normal hinsetzen oder
wenn ihr euch ein sandstein hausmacht
einfach ihr vorsetzen wer da hoch lag
also ich denke das hat auch gefehlt in
minecraft das ganz cool da zugefügt
worden und was ich euch jetzt auch sagen
muss dieses update werde ich in zwei
parts hochladen einfach weil ich jetzt
noch eben schnell diese pyramide da
suchen werde und der nächste partie wird
dann weiß ich nicht heute abend oder
morgen kommen oder so irgendwann so weiß
es nicht jedenfalls werde ich das jetzt
noch aufnehmen und wir sehen uns dann
einfach im zweiten part wären wenn ich
dann die pyramide die neue in den wissen
hinzugefügt wurde gefunden habe also wir
sehen uns dann in den nächsten video
schaut ihr übrigens ja auf jeden fall
mal dann vorbei wenn die pyramiden sehen
sollte passt